so five mio DMT is a specific it's
almost a neurotransmitter the
tryptamines
produced by the human body in the lungs
the cerebrospinal fluid their
fundamental to consciousness itself so
the gut we're talking about before
produces serotonin and we have serrator
genetic pathways which you're very
fundamental to consciousness
Milutin which is in the skin pigment is
in the tryptamine family the tryptamines
are used in ayahuasca and that's why it
can be a great for the visionary
component as well but it's very much a
healing and cleansing and letting go the
indigenous people who have been
custodians of plant medicines understand
they don't just connect us with
consciousness they connect us with our
feeling capacity with the planet and
they remind us to plug back into the web
of life to come home right and so five
Meo is potentially the king of
psychedelic compounds and it is
endogenous to the human brain so there's
been legal tests done with tryptamines
and DMT in the 90s by Rick Strassman he
wrote a book called DMT the spirit
molecule which was made into a
documentary as well and there's other
tests going on at the moment with five
Meo DMT in different organizations
around the world legally as well
but essentially what they believe and
it's still to be fully proven in human
subjects they tested on rats they have
these amazing things where they now grow
human neuronal cells in Petri dishes and
test out tryptamines
on the the brains in a petri dish right
yeah but essentially what they've
discovered is that tryptamines in
general are potentially the thing which
opens the Dreaming every night in sleep
at peak experiences like birth death and
near-death experiences they seem to be
the chemical catalysts for taking us
into the emotional visionary component
of these experiences so all through time
before the 20th century when we started
to develop electromagnetism and polluted
foods and degraded environment sensitive
people and more and more people used to
connect to you know source consciousness
the big G word you know have a feeling
of connection or have a sense even
people who have needeth experiences see
that white light tunnel that sense of
going back to home we
have the capability we're designed to
connect to these deeper realms within
ourselves because everything's
interconnected but it's been degraded
over time not just a one bar signal but
our lifestyle our habits our egos have
degraded our electromagnetic capability
to receive the signal have four five
boxes one mystic still go to caves in
the middle of nowhere and just shut out
the world and go in or people are in
nature they feel better they feel like
they can receive and they can open more
because they're not getting degraded by
by civilization civilization is killing
us if you haven't noticed right so
anyway so anyway tryptamines are native
to our being
I mean they've become very popular in
some of the medicines like ayahuasca
there's another medicine that I work
with in countries where it's legal I
lead retreats over in Mexico as well as
ayahuasca retreats in Peru which is the
bufo alvarius toad now this toad comes
from the Sonoran Desert in the north of
Mexico over into Arizona
it contains 17 or 20 different trace
elements in its glance there's over 400
species of toads in the world this is
the only one which contains five Meo DMT
so there's not an unbroken lineage like
the reefs with ayahuasca in the Amazon
but there is a modern lineage of Mexican
modern people using it having
reintroduced it to some of the Sonoran
indigenous tribes of Mexico and it is
very quickly spread across the world in
the shamanic communities of the west
piggybacking on the popularity of
ayahuasca and other antigens because it
feels like it's time for this because
the experience of five Meo
which is the experience that meditators
can have without an external catalyst is
to reveal essentially that we are the
medicine I feel like there's been a
whole generation in the West I mean this
goes back I mean how long is a piece of
string be you could go all the way back
to the 60s and LSD which basically had
to come through the lab and help open
the minds in the 80s ecstasy came and
helped open the heart in the noughts
plant medicines including ayahuasca came
to clean out the entire body and to
reconnect the soul there seems to have
been a stepping stone over generations
which is very short in Guyon time in
planetary time of if we're killing the
planet she had to get back through to us
right now
I almost feel that human
species is like one strand in the
planetary biome you know yeah it's like
where one strand all the species are
like a micro biome in gaia herself yeah
and we've gone off and so she's trying
to regulate that strand that's going off
it's like where were the probiotics I
know I have all these substances that
she secretes she secretes the
psychoactive substances the mother these
are not illegal these are the plants and
it is the most hubris sort of assumption
to think that plants can be illegal